hey this is presh talwalkar
this problem from the scottish national
five maths exam
is getting a lot of attention because
students felt it was too difficult
chris has an umbrella that is 85
centimeters long
his locker is a cuboid with the length
40 centimeters width 40 centimeters and
height 70 centimeters
can the umbrella fit inside the locker
diagonally between corners p and m
which are opposite corners of the cuboid
i should mention this problem is
recreated from a not yet released exam
so while this may not be the exact
wording i've done my best to recreate
the problem based on posts to twitter
facebook and an article in the scottish
sun
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
one way to solve the problem is to use
the distance formula
imagine setting up a coordinate system
the point p can be placed at the origin
0 0 0.
the point m would then be at a
coordinate of 40 negative 40 and 70.
we can find the distance of pm by using
the distance formula
this becomes the square root of the
quantity 40 squared plus
the quantity negative 40 squared plus 70
squared
this simplifies to be the square root of
8100 which equals 90.
therefore the umbrella can fit because
the locker diagonal is 90 centimeters
which is larger than the umbrella which
is 85 centimeters
another way to solve this problem is to
use the pythagorean theorem twice
in the base square label point n
opposite the corner of p
this makes a right triangle with two
legs of 40. pn is the hypotenuse of this
right triangle so we can calculate the
length of pn as the square root of 40
squared plus 40 squared which equals 40
times the square root of 2.
we can then draw a triangle p and m
and that's another right triangle
this has legs of 40 square root of 2 and
70. so pm is the hypotenuse of this
right triangle and we can calculate its
distance by taking the square root
of the quantity 40 times the square root
of 2 squared plus
70 squared
this again simplifies to be the square
root of 8100 which is 90.
so once again we've calculated pm is 90.
so once again we could say the umbrella
can fit since the locker diagonal is 90
centimeters which is larger than the
umbrella which is 85 centimeters
did you figure it out and do you think
it was too difficult
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you could email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at preshtalwalkar